you can learn firsthand what it's like
to be a cop
without actually being a cop how does
that work bianca holman at the henderson
police department with the scoop on
their citizens academy hey bianca
hey good morning that's a good way of
looking at this the academy started back
in the early 2000s and the goal was to
really continue to build strong
relationships with people here in the
community of henderson so here's a
little bit more about the program it's a
12-week program and it gets a gives you
a look behind the badge of law
enforcement
students go through sessions like use of
force crime scene investigation or even
firearms familiarization julio
machado of henderson pd tells us many
people who participate in the class end
up volunteering with the force or even
joining
my favorite part is interacting with our
citizens just hearing what they value in
a police department and what can we do
to make our department even better and
to serve them
it's one of my favorite things to do
so here is the requirements you gotta
live or work in the city of henderson 18
years old or older no convictions the
academy meets once a week for three
hours and that's for 12 weeks
and then also the department they hold
this academy
twice a year so the spaces are limited
they fill up quickly it's been going on
for a couple years now and the
application is open you guys to the end
of the month reporting live bianca
holman live local now